[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in sallys wels
heute gibt es ein schnelles break rezept
vor kurzem war meine schwiegermutter
auch da und hat uns ein burgic
zubereitet dass er sich heute zu
bereiten werde ist nicht das was meine
schwiegermama gemacht hat das machen wir
irgendwann anders heute gibt es einfach
ein schnelles rezept in zehn minuten
zubereitet und dann auch schnell im ofen
das heißt dieses bild könnte recht
schnell machen was ich hier für vier
wände sind wirklich fertige
lüfterblätter tatsächlich die gibt's
meist im türkischen laden die gibt es
aber auch schon mittlerweile in gut
sortierten supermärkten in der türkei
kriegt man die auch überall ganz frisch
und ihr könnt die blätter natürlich auch
selber machen ihr könnt auch strudel
blätter nehmen oder viele blätter nehmen
aber wie gesagt heute noch einmal
diesmal so weil es schnell gehen soll
und beim nächsten mal da werde ich
meinen die vka starb ausholen und ein
ochse heißt doch türkische bringt und
dann selbst die vka zu retten dann
holman meine schwiegermama dazu und dann
darfst du auch mal was von mir probieren
ja wenn sie noch glaubt dass ich kochen
und backen kann weil ich glaube der
murat ofen weil ich glaube der murat hat
erzählt dass ich das nämlich nicht kann
naja was solls ich mache jetzt erstmal
eine vegetarische version und habe jetzt
hier schon mal die zutaten gerichtet ich
verwende dafür ein 250 gramm sahne
joghurt den zehnprozentigen 200 gramm
sonnenblumenöl 200k mensch etwas pfeffer
und salz für die füllung knapp 500 gramm
beziehungsweise 450 gramm weichkäse
etwas petersilie und zum bestreuen
schwarzkümmel und sesam und hier dann
noch dicker bretter ja dann nehmt ihr
euch jetzt am besten eine große schüssel
da kommt es allein wenn man jetzt
nämlich erst mal so eine art soße
dass ich die barrick soße
ich hab meine also meine schwiegermama
hat schon öfter mal was von mir sie
glaubt dass auch einer der söhne kochen
und backen kann aber beim letzten mal
als sie probiert hatte habe ich halt
gerade dieser drei säfte gemacht so
spinat saft rote beete saft karottensaft
hat sich business wird gesicht verzogen
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen aber sechs
schmeckt so also deswegen ich glaube
schon dass es ihr geschmeckt hat er
wollte nur den dritten nicht probieren
vielleicht weil es ihr zu viel war
hannah montana baby zu den
kameras in japan
partie ist so süß jedenfalls könnte
jetzt hier erstmal das ei mit dem
joghurt verrühren dann kommt da das öl
dazu
muss auch sagen dass das es früher diese
lüfterblätter gar nicht so im supermarkt
gab noch mal hat die immer selber
gemacht also ich erinnere mich ganz gut
dran mit meiner mama habe ich immer
öfter blätter selber gemacht schon ganz
früh samira kann das nämlich auch ganz
gut und ich würde ganz gerne wenn wir
das dann machen sie mir anna schmidt
abzunehmen die hilft nämlich total gerne
in der küche kann
jetzt noch salz und pfeffer dazu
und dann habt ihr hier so eine basis und
dies auch ganz wichtig dass das ein
bisschen flüssiger ist weil diese
lüfterblätter teilweise schon vor
gebacken sind und diese sind ja so ein
bisschen trocken das heißt da muss
einfach so ein bisschen feuchtigkeit
rhein ist denn fett mit dazu und
natürlich geschmack
[Musik]
für die sauce kommt zur seite dann die
petersilie dass jetzt eine die glatte
petersilie die hat auf jeden fall mehr
geschmack die finde ich echt immer
perfekt ich muss aber sagen dass die
causa peter seele im garten besser
wächst aber trotzdem versuche ich immer
mit der glatte petersilie und die wächst
eigentlich auch im hochbett ganz gut der
selbst natürlich vom supermarkt 1000 max
grad bei uns nix und diese harten großen
stile die verwende ich jetzt nicht weil
die einfach zu fest sind aber ich
schmeiß ja auch nicht weg da ist nämlich
so viel vitamin c drin und dann mache
ich das später entweder den saft oder
den smoothie und dann kommt es damit
rein oder wird in den salat geschnitten
das ist immer ganz gut und ich muss
sagen als kind habe ich petersilie
gehasst ich mochte sie gar nicht im berg
schon drei mal gar nichts von drei mal
gemacht und jetzt mittlerweile mag ich
nicht kenne
[Musik]
ich muss sagen ich liebe auch petersilie
meine kinder übrigens auch also ich
sitze wirklich da und es dann so am
strauch wie so ein kleiner großer panda
bear und
samira und lassen die auch gern ich
glaube immer dass den kindern so vorlebt
und die so ein bisschen dran gewöhnt er
lag geht zum beispiel auch in garten und
holt sich einfach so ein strauch fenchel
und ist eben weil sie sagt wenn sie
brauche ich weiß dann hat dann ist zahlt
fenzl und dann macht ihr das auch durch
echt süß wie gut das haben wir jetzt der
weichkäse
da muss ich sagen das deck nicht so mein
lieblings käse ist der hat zwar 60
prozent fettanteil aber der macht zwar
echt lecker und cremig und würzig da
braucht man sonst nichts mehr
[Musik]
das schon mal schön verrühren
ihr könnt sie auch gerne noch gewürze
dazugeben
ich muss allerdings sagen dass ich das
so vor am liebsten mag einfach nur mit
petersilie
[Musik]
nehmt ihr euch eine offene form ich habe
jetzt hier eine mittelgroße im ofen vor
da kommt etwas olivenöl rein
das wird dann schon verstrichen
also eigentlich sind jetzt die falschen
blätter und ich hab da nicht drauf
geachtet beim kaufen das ist nämlich so
ganz ganz tolle das sind wirklich so
viele blätter es gibt noch luft blätter
die ein bisschen dicker sind ist aber
gar nicht schlimm denn
da seht ihr wissen recht spontan ich bin
spontan ich nehme jetzt einfach die
blätter
und dann kommt jetzt erst mal eine
untere schicht rhein und die darf so ein
bisschen übers blech fragen
das ist echt schlimm also da gibt es
verschiedene wie gesagt und manches
entdecker meinen dünner alles gut
hauptsache ihr könnt das blech jetzt gut
erst mal ausgleichen als unterste
schicht und wenn ihr jetzt hier
praktisch diese erste schicht habt kommt
schon mal von der soße was rein
[Musik]
dann etwas käse
und immer schön drauf achten dass nicht
alle sind der mitte landet sondern
wirklich bis zum rand füllung dran kommt
und dann schichtet ihr einfach diese
blätter da rein und dann kommt immer
wieder soße immer mehr käse bis die form
volles und hier gucke ich dass daran
nicht so dick wird das heißt hier gerne
auch mal was wegreißen
[Musik]
wir können da auch meine schicht
gestalten hier indem ihr einfach nur die
abgerissenen teile verwendet und dann
immer nur darauf achten dass immer
wieder soße reinkommt damit es birgt
eben nicht trocken wird die letzte
schicht da schaut ihr am besten dass ihr
einfach noch ein paar yuca blätter habt
also ich habe jetzt meistens hier eine
doppelte schicht gelegt weil die
wirklich sehr sehr dünn sind und die
einfach beim auseinandernehmen schon ein
bisschen zerreißen das aber gar nicht
schlimm das sieht man später organ hat
hier noch diese reste rein
dann habe ich jetzt hier noch ein paar
blätter
zum abdecken und es könnte auch gern so
ein bisschen weil ich jetzt drauf legen
sie dann später auch ganz hübsch aus
dann ein bisschen
von der soße
und jetzt so ein bisschen haushalten mit
der sauce dass ihr so
ungefähr so einen kleinen becher voll
noch übrig habt also ungefähr 100
milliliter
dann klappt das nämlich hier außen noch
ein
[Musik]
dann habe ich jetzt hier die letzte
schicht drauf hier noch etwas von der
soße da kommt jetzt noch mal ein ei dazu
kurz ein
und dann kommt es hier noch drauf
und es geht doch recht schnell und ihr
könnt ja echt ganz tolle zutaten
resteverwertung machen können auch
gemüse mit reinpacken ihr könnt
hackfleisch mit dazu geben alles was ihr
mögt alles was er gerne habt einfach
hier rein und
stand button
[Musik]
schwarz gewinnt dürfte übrigens nicht
verwechseln mit kreuzkümmel oder
normalem kümmel der schmeckt nämlich
komplett anders schwarz grün hat echt
richtig schönen intensiven geschmack und
es übrigens auch sehr gesund also
schwarzkümmelöl zb mega gesagt ja das
bringt es fertig kommt in den
vorgeheizten ofen und ich bin kann ich
kann mich nur eine zweite version der
füllung was sagt ihr ja doch die mach
mal
[Musik]
für die zweite fülle und nämlich 500
gramm hackfleisch marmor in der zwiebel
und knoblauchzehe etwas olivenöl
ich habe ich etwas spinat und nochmal
petersilien zweispitz paprika in rot
etwas paprika merck hier habe ich noch
gewürze und zwar minze und werkbund
etwas wasser und ich habe ich so wie
vorher auch schon die bloße noch mal ein
ei zum bestreichen sesam und
schwarzkümmel und was ich noch vergessen
habe salz pfeffer super dann könnt ihr
am besten schon mal die pfanne leicht
erwärmen mit olivenöl ich nehme jetzt
einfach eine große pfanne da geht es
nämlich unglaublich schnell darin weil
man eben eine große fläche hat falls ihr
keine große pfanne hat eine kleinere
dann könnt ihr das hackfleisch zum
beispiel in zwei schritten anbraten
damit einfach wenn so kalt vielleicht
auch eine heiße pfanne trifft ist es oft
so dass es anfängt zu kochen statt zu
braten und ich weder das sich röstaromen
habt also wird es jetzt schön heiß
angebraten
aber während das jetzt hier noch erwärmt
kann ich hier schon mal die zwiebel und
knoblauchzehe schneiden
geschämt habe ich sie nämlich schon da
denke ich mir halt dann oft okay jetzt
habe ich glaube ich oft genug in dem
video gezeigt wie man zwiebeln schält
und schneidet wenn ihr sagt nee zeigt
sich jedes mal dann zeige ich es ok
jedes mal ab was sind so manche
arbeitsschritte die ich glaub ich
mittlerweile einfach zu sparen kann
ausgesagt ihr braucht noch die basics
können auch mal so so gemüse basic
machen zum beispiel das hat glaube ich
ganz gut fahren so beim schneiden
eingefallen so ein gemüse des monats und
dann können wir das also in der
community bestimmen immer so ein gemüse
des monats und dann wird das gemüse im
monat so ein bisschen so durchgezogen
das heißt man kann ja auf die saison
achten und so coole rezept an damit wir
uns alle gesünder ernähren und
vielseitig
[Musik]
kommt hier das hackfleisch ein
schön fröhlich anbraten
[Musik]
und dann auch gerne die zwiebeln und
knoblauch würfel dazugeben und schön
mitbraten so ungefähr 23 minuten das
kann hier vor sich hin braten so lange
kann ich auch schon mal die paprika
schneiden
und ich muss sagen bei paprika oder mark
spitz paprika am liebsten nicht einsieht
warum eigentlich schmeckt irgendwie
gleich aber ich finde es irgendwie
konsistenz ist anders und auch ich mag
einfach die spitze amerika es ist
einfach so
[Musik]
die paprika ist jetzt gewürfelt und
kommt jetzt auch dazu
da beim spinat schneide ich jetzt auch
den harten strunk weg ich glaube später
gibt einfach ein petersilien spinat
smobil den und die petersilie jetzt auch
noch fein hacken und dann haben auch die
füllung gleich geschafft
gebt denen dann auch hier mit dazu
[Musik]
dann noch das paprika mag dazu mit
wasser ablöschen und
dann können das jetzt eigentlich gleich
würzen mit salz und pfeffer dann mit
minze und berg bohnenkraut
[Musik]
okay die füllung ist jetzt fertig ihr
könnt ihr auch ganz gerne abschmecken
ihr könnt auch zum beispiel diese
geschmacks olivenöl verwenden wie
rosmarin oder chili olivenöl knoblauch
olivenöl
ich werde jetzt einfach mit dem rosmarin
olivenöl die vom einfetten dann habe ich
nämlich mein rosmarin geschmack da drin
[Musik]
und damit dieses gerät genauso
geschichte wird das andere also hier ein
bisschen was über stehen lassen dann die
einzelnen schichten dazwischen und das
geht jetzt auch recht flott
sagen gut dass hier ist da jetzt keine
zehn minuten bürger mehr weil man die
füllung halt schon ein bisschen kochen
und zubereiten muss aber die findung ist
ja auch wenn man alles abwickeln ab bis
zu 20 mrd
[Musik]
ok jetzt die zweite person gleich fertig
so
schön alles drauf
dann bestreuen und ab in den ofen und
dann wird gleich probiert und das break
ist ganz praktisch man kann es nämlich
warm und kalt essen wobei ich sagen muss
frisch aus dem backofen ist es schon am
besten man kann es aber auch mal ganz
gut einfrieren und wieder aufwärmen und
wenn wir echt mal so viel übrig da haben
und ist wirklich so zwei drei tage im
kühlschrank war dann tut es einfach im
kloster das auch lecker da kriegt man so
der richtige kruste
[Musik]
mein weg ist fertig und heute darf
styling probieren
er hat schon mal probiert
doch damit
noch gar nicht helmig seit kurzem bei
uns in themen und er schneidet die
videos sehr gut zog
das freut nicht alle noch gar nicht dem
video probiert was ist alles immer
backstage höher ach das stimmt neulich
habe ich nämlich ich weiß habe ich zum
tode nämlich gesagt hol mal jemanden zum
probieren erstanden sie alle zu finden
also ich hab dich gemacht einmal mit
käse und einmal mit so einer hackfleisch
gemüse finden also da hab ich gern
beides probiert ein mögliches problem
ist okay das team hat übrigens auch das
video geschnitten als meine
schwiegermama
das war schon ein wichtiges thema da war
ja schon ich tot gelacht
mit schilden dachte ich der stoffe
stecken oder ja ich glaube das ist
richtig doch bisher schwierig aus der
hand
ich glaub ich bleibe bei meinem einem
käse käse übrig
und dann machen wir später einfach im
salat dazu
gibt's heute fertig mit salat
frisch wurde ja
ich finde das so richtig weiß
stimmt ihnen geld
trocken geworden oder ich gut das tut
gewonnen sehr gut
ich finde mit zur fertig hilft da muss
man aufpassen dass nicht trocknet aber
ich glaube so mit der büchse das passt
ganz gut und oben schön kross innen
schön weich
es gibt es bei euch daher auch meine
sperre ab und zu ja ja
das bringt die roma vorbei
von der oma schmeckt sie machen wissen
ja auch mal rezept dem nämlich mehr zeit
und machen das machen sie es kann alles
bin ich auch und ich muss auch sagen
wenn man bei mir zuhause früher gab es
mehr ganz so meine mama ist echt
aufgemacht ich mache das tatsächlich
nicht ganz so oft weil ich weiß jetzt
nicht aber wir sind ja auch nicht so ein
riesen haushalt so bei uns insofern gut
wenn ich jetzt mein team dazu zählen ist
aber schon großer türkische haushalte
gemischt alles durchgemischt aber ich
glaube wir können auch gar nicht so viel
gepäck und brot essen wie man es
vielleicht früher ob machte ich weiß
aber irgendwas ist ein bisschen
verändert geld für mich auch jetzt hat
man schon ein bisschen mehr mann
reduziert so ein bisschen die
kohlenhydrate iss mehr gemüse keine
proteine weil also ich könnte zeit davon
so ewig viele stücke essen ich kann
schon aber ich kann schon das ganze
essen ja ja eigentlich schon sehr gut
eigentlich schauen ja doch also dass man
fleisch ist auch das finde ich sehr
lecker
das probiere ich gleich ich vertrau dir
dass du sagen so schlecker und wenn ihr
das land machen wollt dann folgt jetzt
auch gerne mal aus
moskau man spricht nicht mit vollem an
wenn ihr das auch mal ausprobieren wollt
dann schaut gerne auf meinem blog vorbei
dort verlinkt ich euch nämlich beide
rezepte sowohl einmal mit fleisch als
auch mit hackfleisch
also mittags flash genau und ich werde
demnächst noch wir haben nämlich als
meine schwiegermama da war noch ein
video aufgenommen da hat sie mir auf dem
boden auch so einem grill auf einem ofen
bürger zubereitet und dann habe ich dann
lade ist jetzt auch mal ein und lasst
ihr dann auch bei mir direkt probieren
da mal was ganz anderes ich bin gespannt
und ich bin gespannt darauf ob sie dann
auch schmeckt also probiert gern aus
viel spaß dabei bis zum nächsten mal
ja cool da war das heute eine premiere
rasch aufgeregt ich bin ich kriege mal
so weiche knie endlich könnte geradeso
zusammen
mit dem update angemerkt
besser machte
[Musik]